début de la cinquième semaine du procès
des attentats de janvier 2015 les
audiences d'aujourd'hui sont terminées
elles se sont tenues dans un contexte
particulier trois jours après l'attaqué
à l'armé blanche de vendredi à paris à
proximité des anciens locaux de charlie
hebdo
le point avec katia technique la cour
d'assises spéciale de paris
on entre dans une nouvelle phase du
procès celle du fond c'est à dire que
les auditions vont permettre de
comprendre comment les attentats ont été
minutieusement préparée et surtout
partie deux enquêteurs de la section
antiterroriste sont venus détailler la
téléphonie des frères quoi chez les
dames et 10 coulibaly on a appris qu al
mehdi coulibaly disposer de pas moins de
17 lignes évidemment un grand nombre
officieuse les trois terroristes se sont
concertés juste avant les attentats pour
envoyer le top départ
et puis un chef de secteur de la brigade
criminelle est venu expliquer que selon
lui au vu de l'arsenal dont dispose et à
mehdi coulibaly et bien il aurait dû
avoir un complice pour l'attentât de
l'hyper cacher la téléphonie a aussi
révélé qu avait dit à coulibaly a
multiplié les contacts avec certains des
accusés qui se trouve dans le box alors
au sujet des complicités
je vous propose d'écouter deux avocates
de la partie civile
lorsqu'on se rend compte que la
téléphonie
de coulibaly va vers des accusés entre
septembre et janvier jusqu'à 700 fois
600 x 500 fois on se rend compte qu'il
ya même des liens très étroits entre
avait dit coulibaly et les accusés donc
on cela maintenant on va petit à petit
démêler l'écheveau est allé dans
techniquement leur implication ce qui a
rendu possible ce qu'on a exposé en
début de ce procès les liens sont
précisés grâce à ce genre
d'investigation que ce soit les les
recherches téléphoniques l'étude des
fadettes et les recoupements qui ont pu
être faits et ensuite les empreintes
c'est l'ensemble de
de ces indices kiki qui emmène
aux personnes qui font le lien entre les
attentats et les personnes qui sont
aujourd'hui accusés et c'est la raison
pour laquelle d'ailleurs ces personnes
sont dans le box
et puis la fameuse vidéo d'allégeance à
l'état islamique dames et 10 coulibaly a
été diffusée on entre alors dans un
autre monde à mehdi coulibaly fait des
pompes dévoile son arsenal d'armes
gigantesque et puis il se prépare donc à
affronter
selon lui les ennemis de l'islam il
déclame en langue arabe et en langue
française mais qui a monté cette vidéo
en effet elle a été après les attentats
puisqu'on y voit des séquences de
l'hyper cacher quand vous le voyez il ya
encore de nombreux mystères dans cette
enquête et les auditions au fil du temps
vont peut-être permettre de déterminer
qui sont les véritables coupables